welcome to this video playing deck on I
really need to learn that some some
point how this is pronounced this show I
don't know maybe someone with an Italian
background should tell me in the notes
ok we have a sloth he's played the slide
with he takes e4 against Knight c3
that's an interesting way to play as
black pretty decent equalizing chances
mr. Castle side I don't know the exact
to move orders here I know that white is
playing Bishop hmm I wonder maybe sure I
should play Bishop g5 even yeah why not
Bishop d2 was what I was thinking about
okay it's clear that I need to reroute
the snide interesting mmm I thought
Bishop a6 really hmm I wonder okay let's
do that it's an interesting strategical
idea maybe it's bad i don't know the
ideas he couldn't take with the pawn due
to e6 and now it's not so clear to me if
Bishop a6 is really helping him and the
bishop on g5 is slightly annoying he
cannot really play Bishop e7 here or
maybe he can maybe he can the King in
the middle
yeah down how do you develop now I mean
maybe g5 but this is of course gives me
something to attack yeah this this is a
kind of mission accomplished Thank it at
least the idea the general idea worked
but now what probably let's fix fix the
kingside with h 5 so that i can never
switch a piece over yeah the idea is
moving the night and then Queen g4 look
each EG g g3 this kind of the scandal
firm action yum here i thought this one
but maybe it can go not clear I mean
Bishop c4 it's not threatening much i
can i can just recapture if it takes and
that's surprising I thought this would
help me really bear it maybe maybe not
aha Quincy to ya so this needs to be
prevented but I don't mind that Queen a
rock g3 sm a useful look left anyway
okay but well where is it going on here
the know I probably here so that I have
Queen g4 edition b3 is questionable I
guess I'd we can see three so this is
probably not a move that I want to play
b3 yeah but what it does is it it it it
makes night moves possible maybe Quincy
to remove from the neither three days
Quincy to
hmm yeah maybe just 24 then Queen h4
yeah i'm unsure but i don't want to
spend more time the night only one it
was useful to have it because the Quincy
to was nuisance but I mind my I must get
the night involved to the into the
attack other than otherwise i will never
really get something serious going maybe
93 and then switch over to e6 like did
93 94 rook f3 and then try to sac
somewhere oh that's that's a surprising
move a thought night here with 95 would
be a problem
maybe even be three and then night yeah
come on and I want to get rid of this
Queen and then night here
whoops human and the Chocolate check
first is better yeah he needs to play
King head and group see one now John I'm
not sure that at the end of it I have
anything i need the night I need the
night form for the attack interesting
wants to get to g5
okay okay I need to get to see Five here
just what would of course be helpful
Quincy three days Roxy one winning the
Queen for rock end yeah yeah this is
okay and i get to see Five now now no
Queen trade please not under this
circumstances
oh really this looks very weakening rg6
is hanging as well now 25 go okay Quincy
fibers night not the end of the world
but still I should have prevented it
probably check check check time warning
check check nice playing for for my time
oops okay well that's even a counter
play I didn't I didn't really appreciate
that check check check
check draw offered
check check check yeah of course it's
rather winning on time than playing a
draw here check check check check white
portraits on time yeah just a great
player he never ever had anything in
this game just dead lost basically all
the time I just let's say completely
worse damn sure yeah this counter play
it was was slightly problematic g5
wasn't wasn't really good allowing Queen
a 7 I mean look at this King hear
something like this its own its I mean
even yeah even the way it was played at
a probably just check check check yeah
this end game is also good for white i'm
pretty sure i still have this pollen the
e-file but it's it's a matter of
position and this is probably not enough
this leads to a draw of course cha this
is even easier using but ok it's not a
matter of chess anymore just chuck just
time timed here can take here just does
this is this is winning maybe i can do
it in seven seconds maybe the jeep onus
is running but no time it was an
interesting positional game where you
made many many mistakes position
positionally Bishop c4 takes b3 is just
bad i mean it just it just helps white
and until black is in very bad shape
it's just ajust a bad position i can
always play on the king site yes
thing on the queenside and there are
various ways to to make progress I could
also in this position playbook see one
which is quite good he needs to go here
and queen air form I saw all that as
well and I wasn't sure what is the
maximum at this position is and okay
what happened was was okay as he allowed
me to go to c5 and g6 is just just crazy
I mean this just gives it away
completely opening up and 44 this is
this now but really lost I mean before
it was just clearly better but this is
not defensible anymore yeah and i didn't
i didn't really didn't really convert
this here Luke g6 us even stronger yeah
many many possible ways to to win this
just not the way out and how I played
this was just taking taking too many
moves with the so little time okay
thanks for watching